la guerre qui a poussé plus de 5
millions d'ukrainiens à quitter leur
pays mais certains d'entre eux ne
seraient pas libres de leurs mouvements
car moscou est accusé d'avoir déporté
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
russie d'ailleurs le président zielinski
évoque la question depuis des semaines
il parle de migration forcée vers la
russie et de son côté moscou annonce
cinq cent mille réfugiés ukrainien sur
son sol bonjour oriane verdier vous êtes
l'envoyé spécial de rfi à odessa vous
avez pu recueillir des témoignages de
personnes qui ont pu sortir les
territoires sous contrôle russe la
question des camps de filtration revient
tel fréquemment eh bien oui c'est en
même temps un sujet omniprésent et en
même temps assez étrangement absent en
fait tout le monde en parle sans en
parler parce qu'on n'a pas de preuve
concrète ce les informations qui nous
arrive viennent surtout de personnes qui
sont déjà en russie qui sont donc passés
par ces cons de filtration mais ces
personnes ont semble-t-il peur de
s'exprimer et donc elle ne donne que
deux des informations très brève nous
avons notamment discuter avec une
personne de marioupol donc déplacé de
marioupol donc son neveu a pu a réussi à
l'appeler depuis un de ses camps de
filtration il lui a dit qu'on lui avait
pris son téléphone et qu'il n'a été pas
en effet libres de parler et surtout
qu'ils avaient peur soit d'être envoyé
en russie soit pire encore d'être
réquisitionnés pour combattre au sein de
la république populaire de de neste qui
dépend donc de la russie donc combattre
contre son propre peuple alors ce qui
est certain c'est que marioupol semble
être la principale cible de ces
déplacements forcés et les habitants de
la région de kherson entre odessa et
marioupol craignent d'être les prochains
puisque les forces russes ont annoncé
qu'elle allait boucler la région pour
organiser un référendum d'indépendance
en tout cas un référendum plus ou moins
réguliers comme nous explique les
habitants de cette région
oriane vous trouvez actuellement à
odessa pour rfi c'est le grand port au
sud de l'ukraine qui se préparait au
début de la guerre à une offensive qui
n'est finalement jamais arrivé comment
vit-on aujourd'hui l'offensive qui est
lancée dans le donbass alors ici on a
toujours par bien sûr d'être la cible
l'offensive même si comme vous disiez
pour l'instant la cible principale est
évidente et le dombass odessa et donc
stratégique puisque c'est un c'est le
grand port au sud le seul porte toujours
sur la mer noire toujours sous contrôle
le ukrainien est ici tout comme dans le
reste du pays on se prépare à une
résistance sur le long terme puisque
cette guerre dure il y as nous sommes
notamment avec ma collègue la plage ou
nadia aller dans un centre
d'entraînement militaire ou des
personnes nous expliquait dans un
premier temps s'être engagé
humanitairement pour aller aider les
déplacés et puis aujourd'hui prendre des
cours militaires à prendre a tiré à la
kalachnikov apprendre à répondre avec
les armes puisqu'il pense un jour devoir
répondre ainsi à une offensive sur
odessa pour l'instant la personne le
militaire qui a organisé cet
entraînement nous disait que l'armée ne
demande pour l'instant que des
volontaires avec des réelle formation
militaire mais chacun se tient prêt à
agir
puisque on a on a donc peur que ça
vienne jusqu'ici nous avons également
parlé avec des membres de la cyberarmée
donc le gouvernement a mis en place une
toute une initiative qui appelle chaque
citoyen à mener des cyber attaques sur
la russie selon vos compétences vous
pouvez mener des attaques plus ou moins
importantes